hé, fais-le, je suis le chauffeur, tu as appelé ça une petite
amie dans le coma, la carte de crédit n'était pas
valide, ok,
tu ne vas pas me demander si elle est rentrée à la maison,
ok, j'aurai besoin
des téléphones portables de ton appareil photo, de tout ce que tu as pu utiliser
pour enregistrer ce que tu as fait.  ici ce soir,
j'ai frappé à la mauvaise porte, ce soir,
c'est lui qui attire toujours oui monsieur, assurez-vous que
j'ai une note de cinq étoiles
oui
[Musique]
Robert, je ne pense pas que ce soit génial que vous
aidiez tous ces gens au hasard et
tout, mais ça ne va pas  remplis
ce trou dans ton cœur,
je suis obligé de te dire ces choses, je ne suis
peut-être qu'ami avec ça, Mac Susan est
parti, cela fonctionne dans un monde dangereux,
qu'est-ce que la vidéo, toute la surveillance,
quelque chose d'autre s'est passé dans cette pièce,
allez, faites-le, qui que nous soyons  ils recherchent
des assassins à un niveau élevé, ils
nettoient, personne n'est en sécurité
[Musique]
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce que vous venez de commencer, vous
l'avez récupéré, vous partez en guerre avec
moi
[Musique]
libérez la bête, l'erreur qu'ils ont commise a été de
tuer  mon ami,
il n'y a pas de retour possible,
nous devons tous payer pour nos péchés
[Musique]